>>> WELCOME TO PROGRAM, THE
UNITED STATES SPECIAL IRAN ENJOY
IS HEAD BACK TO EUROPE TO WORK
ON REVIVING THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL.
THE CURTAIN HAS BEEN PULLED BACK
ON HOW IRANIAN FOREIGN POLICY
WORKS.
AN EXTRAORDINARY AND THREE HOUR
RECORDING WITH THE FOREIGN
MINISTER AND CHIEF NUCLEAR
NEGOTIABLER HAD BEEN LEAKED IN
WHICH HE CRITICIZES IRAN'S R
REVOLUTIONARY GUARDS FOR
UNDERMINING THE COUNTRY.
RUSSIA AS WELL SAYING ALL WE'RE
TRYING TO SABOTAGE THE NUCLEAR
DEAL.
THIS FALL OUT IN THE UNITED
STATES FOR CHIEF NEGOTIATOR, THE
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE JOHN
KERRY AFTER HE ASSERTED HE TOLD
HIM OF ISRAELI AIR STRIKES.
KERRY DENIES ANY SUCH
CONVERSATION TOOK PLACE.
JOINING ME ON THIS IS AN IRAN
ANALYST AND SENIOR FELLOW AT THE
CARNEGIE ENDOWMENT IN
WASHINGTON.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
WHY DO YOU THINK THIS WAS LEAKED
AND WHY DOES IT MATTER?
>> IT'S TOUGH TO SAY WHY IT WAS
LEAKED.
I ASSUME ENEMIES OF THE FOREIGN
MINISTER WHO LEAKED THE TAPE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE A
FUTURE FOR HIM IN IRANIAN
POLITICS.
I DON'T THINK HE HIMSELF LEAKED
IT.
THERE ARE TWO PARALLEL REGIMES
WORKING IN CONCERT IN IRAN.
YOU HAVE A DEEP STATE LED BY THE
SUPREME LEADER AND THE
REVOLUTION FLAIARY GUARDS.
THEY CULTIVATE REGIONAL M
MALITIAS.
THEY CRUSH DESCENT IN IRAN.
IN SOME CASES THEY CONDUCT
ASSASSINATIONS.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER PARALLEL STATE
IN IRAN WHICH IS LED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE VERY LITTLE POWER BUT
THEY HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY.
ONE OF THINGS THAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT IN THIS INTERVIEW
IS THE FACT HE IS SOMEONE WHO IS
BEEN POWERLESS.
THE POWER IN IRAN BELONGS TO THE
SUM
SUPREME LEADER AND REVOLUTIONARY
GUARDS.
AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF ABSORBING
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ALL THAT GOES
WRONG IN IRAN, I THINK HE WAS
TRYING TO REVEAL SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL KNEW WHICH IS
ACCOUNTABILITY BELONGS ELS
E
ELSEWHERE.
>> THIS IS WHAT HE SAID TO THAT
END AND HE BELONGED TO THAT DEEP
STATE MILITARY COMPLEX YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
HERE IS THE CONVERSATION.
>>.
>> IT KIND OF CONFIRMS THE
NATURE OF THE IRANIAN REGIME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK PRACTICALLY IT
MEANS ABOUT, FOR INSTANCE, LET'S
TAKE THE THING THAT THE UNITED
STATES AND EUROPE IS VERY
INVOLVED IN RIGHT NOW WANTING TO
GET BACK TO A NUCLEAR ARMS
CONTROL AGREEMENT WITH IRAN.
>> I DON'T THINK THIS CHANGES
MINDS IN WASHINGTON OR EVEN
EUROPE PER SE.
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON HAVE LONG
KNOWN HE'S A MESSENGER AND NOT
SOMEONE WHO MAKES POLICY IN
IRAN.
DURING THE OPEN YEARS THERE WAS
HOPE.
IT COULD EMPOWER THESE MORE
MODERATE FORCES.
I DON'T THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAD THE SAME KIND
OF HOPE.
NOT NECESSARILY BECAUSE THEY
PLOOEF IT WILL BRING ABOUT A
TRON
TRANSFORMATION IN IRAN.
I SUSPECT THE EUROPEANS THE
SAME.
IT SDRUK ME THE WHOLE TIME HE
WAS DESCRIBING HIS JOB AS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN LIKE A JANITOR
AND A FIREFIGHTER IN THAT HE WAS
ESSENTIALLY TASKED WITH CLEANING
UP THE MESS OF THE REVOLUTIONARY
GUARDS AND BRINGING THE COUNTRY
OUT OF CRISIS.
HE WAS IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION THESE LAST EIGHT YEARS
AND HE NOW WANTS TO COME CLEAN,
PERHAPS ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
>> THIS WAS LABELED AS A SERIOUS
OF INTERVIEWS WITH THE OUT GOING
MINISTERS.
THAT'S HOW THE INTERVIEWER
LABELED THESE AND CERTAINLY HE
HAD A LONG CONVERSATION WITH
ZAREF.
WERE YOU SURPRISED AS OTHERS
HAVE BEEN IN THE REVOLUTION
ABOUT RUSSIA NOT NECESSARILY
PLAYING GOOD COP IN THE IRAN
NUCLEAR NEGOTIATIONS OR WITH THE
DEAL.
>> KIND OF SAYING RUSSIA WAS
QUITE HAPPY TO SEE IT SABOTAGED.
LET ME PLAY THIS EXCERPT.
RUSSIA IS INVOLVED, ALONG WITH
CHINA AND EUROPEANS IN GETTING
THAT NUCLEAR DEAL BACK TOGETHER
AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK RUSSIA'S GAME
IS IN THIS?
>> THERE'S A WIDESPREAD BELIEF
WITHIN IRAN AND FRANKLY, I TO
SOME EXTEPNT SHARE THIS VIEW THT
RUSSIA BENEFITS FROM AN ISOLATED
IRAN.
RUSSIA DOESN'T WANT TO SEEM THEM
EMERGE FROM IELATISOLATION FOR
NUMBER OF REASONS.
IRAN BY VIR STUE OF THE FACT IT
ISOLATED, IT HASN'T EXPLOITED
THE VAST GAS RESERVE.
IT'S NOT REALLY COMPETING WITH
RUSSIA.
NUMBER TWO AS LONG AS IRAN IS
ISOLATED, IRAN IS DEPEN DENT ON
RUSSIA TSTRATEGICALLY.
ALL THAT SAID, I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE EVIDENCE THAT SUGGESTS THAT
RUSSIA HAS BEEN TRYING TO
UNDERMINE THE NUCLEAR AGREEMENT.
I DO AGREE THAT RUSSIA DOESN'T
BENEFIT FROM A